live stream let's go alright what's up
everyone and welcome to simulation we
have a great episode for you today we
are gonna be talking about better
cryptocurrencies and to do so we have
Jean Hoffman I thanks for coming on to
the show thanks for having me greatly
appreciate it and you are an investor
and advisor at Shia mm-hmm that's great
and you also work as a as a board as a
board member and interim CTO at AE token
that's correct and then previously at
venetie which you founded and sold
that's great and so we have a lot to
unpack about better cryptocurrencies
absolutely yeah let's figure this out
because we have a lot of progress to go
and figuring out how to best exchange
units for things and services yeah well
you know look there's an old joke I run
at people who said they've been
encrypted currency for a long time and
asked them how long they say something
like 7 or 10 years and I'm like I've
been in at 20 because you know this is a
set of problems that people been trying
to solve since the late 90s the original
cypherpunks movement it's very much a
you know needed core piece but there
were all these kind of critical security
and computer science problems that had
to have novel solutions frankly and you
know the neat thing about Bitcoin is
it's almost perfect but the almost is
actually one of its critical flaws
mm-hmm okay so I now I want to ask it's
like you you and Eddie we're making a
joke before the show that
cryptocurrencies been around longer than
currency has I don't know if it's a it's
longer than currency has but it's
certainly much much longer than like
what people think of as the Crypt of
course 20 years I mean that's yeah
that's really long it doesn't act we
don't actually think that it's been
around that long yeah there are things
called like a David Toms trauma and
digital cash digit cash yeah but it had
a single point of failure and you know
if you've watched what's happening in
modern times when the technology that
nobody wants to round has a single point
of failure well things like Napster
happen and then one day after gets shut
down and then things like BitTorrent
rise and they're truly decentralized and
a very similar pattern and
from you know what the late 90s
cypherpunks wanted to Bitcoin and he
just give us a quick education on the
single point of failure of Napster and
then also the rise of Victoria sure yeah
so you know Napster went out and said
okay we're gonna need centralized
servers and we're going to make it so
when you download our software will
automatically find all your mp3 files
and publish them but that meant that
there was a central server that somebody
could go shut down and the next step was
for Bram Cohen to go out and build
BitTorrent which was a truly
peer-to-peer protocol it required no
real single point of failure so you know
the game of Wacom wall that would have
to be done by governments to try to stop
it would be extremely hard interesting
so ok so rather than the centralization
of all of the power into one centralized
Napster server this peer-to-peer network
of BitTorrent was created making you a
node nyan node whoever's using it a node
and then it decentralized and
distributed the mp3 files and and movies
and everything else to the point where
you know BitTorrent was something like
45% of all Internet traffic before the
rise of OTG television right Wow yeah
and that's over the top which means like
Netflix and write little YouTube it's
actually back when Netflix was just
barely making the transition away from
DVDs BitTorrent was kind of nightly
downloads full song yeah yeah I remember
how using that like whatever was 10 15
years ago wasn't like that no but ok so
that's a really good example of
centralization and decentralization well
in fact so you know to give you a kind
of the reason that Bitcoin really solved
a huge problem when I sold my first
company which built ad blockers to PGP
PGP about a year later was sold to
McAfee and I was deciding what to do
next and it was either start a Down
little music company or start a
cryptocurrency bank and I talked to my
now wife and I said well honey this has
to happen it's critically important for
the future Internet but we'll probably
have to live on some strange Caribbean
island surrounded by armed guards
because well you know you're the central
point of failure for the entire crypt of
Bank and she said you know why don't you
go pick on the record labels yeah
exactly yeah yeah there's we do not want
any sort of family at risk
exactly the centralization but one can
also say interestingly enough even if
whatever becomes decentralized that even
then there is a group of people like
this Bitcoin core or theorem foundation
that can then still be picked up a bit I
mean look you know there's an argument
that a lot of folks make that the one
point of failure is github right I mean
if you think about it that's where the
source is you know often there's a
couple developers but you fundamentally
want to get these projects to a place
you know I use Linux a little bit
because in some ways leena still has a
little too much control of Linux right
but you know right now if leanness was
hit by a bus hopefully he looks both
ways before stepping out there's enough
core developers of Linux of all the
different pieces that it would go
forward no matter what and you know
that's true a bit point as well I mean
you're gonna have a very very hard time
rounding up all the sources of Bitcoin
releases the actual developers and
because the source is out there right
it's on BitTorrent it's you know
available on servers globally you can't
really stuff that genie back in the
bottle and then what is then this point
of failure of Bitcoin although it's
almost perfect what's the point of
failure House Xie better we have a lot
to explore you have you know on the on
the deck here it says green money for a
digital world and it's like a leaf in
the logo so yeah like to tell us about
what listen so there was one assumption
made in solving the Byzantine general
problem proof of work and the idea
around proof of work it would was
originally one CPU one vote so you know
everybody had a laptop you'd be able to
mine and you know our generalized
computers as a bunch of them it was kind
of taking the old SETI and folding it
home and those things forward into the
future but it turns out that that's not
the case
it is completely solvable to make custom
hardware so you've got people put
billion putting billions of dollars into
custom chip fabrications to make proof
of work you know miners write that both
get faster and faster than any
generalized computer can
and then use tremendous amounts of power
I mean we're literally talking about a
you know g20 countries monthly use of
power yeah that is crazy and specialized
chips well and that specialized chips it
has this kind of nasty circular problem
of specialized chips mean investment
mean you can afford to you know go into
partnership with power companies which
centralizes mining more and more and
more and the whole point behind bitcoin
was that everybody should be mine Yeah
right and right now you know you go to
China and you grab two people and you
might have 51% of all Bitcoin money
that's a big problem it's an extremely
big problem because you know as Bitcoin
and war Chia in the future start to
become a reserve currency of the world
all of a sudden nation-states are
playing against nation-states
and in that environment you know having
51% control might be really interesting
to you know stop an arms payment or you
know bankrupt another country there
there's some really you know dangerous
kinds of things that can happen when you
have this kind of level of core
infrastructure reliant on only a few
people yeah and as you know why is my
payment not being processed why is all
of a sudden there's more and more
security around these people that have a
majority of the power contracts that
ship contracts that are doing a lot of
the processing and above the mining so
ok so now that is a that is a central
flaw of what's been built so far that's
right ok it runs through all
cryptocurrencies right now you know
they're people talking about proof
mistake as another solution I think a
lot of people who are talking about
proof of stake kind of either don't have
enough economics background to
understand how dangerous that is I mean
you know George Soros famously broke the
British Pound because the Brits said
we're going to defend it right and
that's what stakes basically are
underneath or Sonique in this case
meaning that they support it yeah you
support the idea would be that you would
put up your currency and use that
currency as the way that you're kind of
validated is someone who could mine
there are all sorts of problems with
that there all sorts of kind of
financial mechanisms you can do to make
that break pretty badly because proof of
work as an idea is excellent but what
proof of work is proving to waste isn't
really good actually and that's where
she comes in
talk about it now so Chia Bram Cohen
Ryan singer looked at this right here
fun in fall 2017
that's right looked at the problem and
said you know look the Bitcoin guys are
right from a security perspective so you
know if anything I would say we're kind
of almost Bitcoin maximalists in the
sense of you know Bitcoin is right and a
lot of these other things trying to be
all things to all people are somewhat
scary but you know like the etherium
community love the ethos right you got a
bunch of people trying to build stuff
that's great but you got to have those
core deep security roots right to be
able to have kind of a global platform
for money and compute write hard enough
to just do money but we looked at it and
Bram came up with an idea called proof
of space and time and it's really proof
of unused space and elapsed a time a
couple different reasons why you need
both but let's talk about proof of space
first because it's kind of that the core
thing that's different it turns out to
solve the Byzantine generals problem you
have two provably waste something and so
the idea was you know back in the day
computer GPU would be what you can be
improve ibly waste well you'd be wasting
energy in the computations right the
idea was you know you had some spare so
you'd use it well it turns out there's a
commodity that a lot of people have a
lot spare of and that's empty hard drive
space interesting and so it's very
interesting in the sense that you know
couple terabytes of you know look we've
had a slight dip in the market in that
now your laptop usually only has about
thirty percent free because of the price
of SSD but even that's about to change
again
so everybody used to buy you know double
the storage they needed and so half of
its at their idle and you know
especially in what I'd call like middle
enterprises where they go you know we're
gonna do this storage install this month
we're install for the next three or four
years so we don't want to bring in
terabytes and terabytes and many of them
to sit idle well all of a sudden you can
download Shia you dad in the proofs of
space in which do is you it's been a few
hours computing a massively parallel
kind of problem that writes out these
lottery tickets is the best way to think
about a cryptographic lottery tickets
and so you fill 300 gigs a terabyte 10
terabytes whatever you kind of have
spare and you can do it in smaller blobs
so that like
using your space up oh I need a new 300
I'll delete one of my and we call it
farming so that's one of your plots okay
right and the idea here is that every
five minutes I like pick one we'll do it
a little faster there'll be a challenge
from the last block and you'll look on
your drive and go do I have the best
answer to that challenge do I have the
bingo card right and if you do you'll
win that blocks rewards yeah but the
thing is is that's pretty quick you know
you look up your hard drive within the
first minute of that block everybody's
gonna figure out who's got the best
proof of space right and then it's the
same sort of idea if I shout out the
answer and everybody else agrees that
that is the right one that's easier to
to say that that is the correct answer
than to come up with though that's right
so but now if you have a couple
petabytes of space you it's easier for
you to store different lottery tickets
right so yeah your your lottery ticket
winning effectiveness rate right is you
got a petabyte and somebody else has a
terabyte you're gonna win ten times more
often than they are directly linearly
right in so then does that also kind of
have the similar problem of these
massive Hardware hard drive farms and no
not really and again this comes back to
two things you know
spinning disk is pretty cheap
electrically right you know and most of
the disks that's spinning is spinning
regardless of whether cheese exists or
not you know your render farm at a major
animation studio is going to be used to
have a lead during production but in
between petabytes just laying there
doing nothing right so we think that
there's a stronger overhead of kind of
unused space but most importantly okay
even if we're wrong every day you know
Hitachi and Western Digital and Seagate
wake up in the morning trying to figure
out how to most cheaply store random
information right and so there's no like
magic bullet that changes us from hard
drives and if it does well great now our
phones will come with like a terabyte
instead of a gigabyte right so when
we're putting that kind of social
pressure and financial pressure on a
commodity we really like doing that with
storage because storage is useful
otherwise an ant minor you know version
X isn't useful to do anything but
eggwin okay so um this is the proof of
space right okay that now I have extra
hard drive space I'm storing lottery
tickets that are a couple megabytes per
lottery ticket the ticket itself or
alike you know it's a text message right
it's not a big piece it's it's like a
hash
it's rash it's exact very small amount
of space but you're putting a bunch of
them on your millions and billions etc
of watery tickets and then every five
minutes there's a call for you know who
has the lottery thing for the next block
that's right and so then there is
actually no computation the computation
comes in front and that's also where
proof of time comes in okay so because
these proofs will be relatively quickly
found you don't have a real easy ability
to kind of have that normal metronomic
you know block rate that Bitcoin has
right this isn't an a random number
generation for the lottery tickets right
no the idea here is what's called a
verifiable delay function so one of the
things that crypto academics have been
trying to solve for a long time is I'd
like to disclose this press release in
24 hours
and I want to post it and I want a piece
of crypto that a lot everybody else once
those 24 hours have elapsed to open it
right so so delaying things has been
something that has kind of been core
academic research and what's starting to
happen with things like ZK Snorks and
others is that you can start doing
things that are very non parallelizable
you know you can only use like one core
on the CPU maybe one and a half and so
you do things like exponentiate or you
can think a hash of a hash of the hash
right but the problem was is that in the
past if you wanted to prove that you've
done five minutes worth of work it would
take everybody five minutes worth of
time to prove it so now we're coming up
with ways that you can take like a 20
minute proof of time it takes like a
second to prove it
so everybody out there on the blockchain
can quickly see that yes this time
server really did the you know
approximately five minutes of work and
the way this all works is proof of space
and time multiplied together so a really
good proof of space takes a little less
to complete and that's how it wins so it
might be like a perfect proof of space
might get done in four minutes instead
of five mm-hmm and so you're constantly
bringing down the amount of time we're
if we're doing a work level adjustment
just like Bitcoin right so you're saying
hey we want these things to end every
five minutes as time servers get faster
that will be harder there'll be more
iterations that are required okay and I
know we all will also visit the the
website which i think is gonna give us
really good insight as well so less
mining centralization no mining waste of
electricity yeah and I mean look the
electricity thing is key right it's been
a big yeah you know look when I took
some time off after selling when do you
see a couple years ago you know I knew
cryptocurrency was what I needed to be
doing I've been in this business in a
sense for 20-plus years it was a
disconcerting thought to think about
like making Bitcoin be the global
reserve currency and you know increasing
annual global energy use by a third
right this is just not a fun concept
when you start scaling it up if it was
that least sustainable like solar or
something it would be different when
well it's still mine but then thing is
that you're still wasting a bunch of
capex I mean like I would rather see the
price of power fall right because you
know a more sustainable way to do right
yeah but I mean you know like let's take
that same sustainability asset and move
it to you know driving and desalinating
and you know like actual usable things
because you know there's certainly this
argument that maybe bitcoins energy use
is overhyped because well visa runs
servers and all of this but in reality
you know you're not specifically
choosing to waste electricity in the
other ways this works right correct
here we're saying it is true that you
have to choose something to waste to
have the security that's necessary to do
a blockchain right right and so we'd
much rather choose storage and we'd much
rather have storage be something that
you know everybody can use you know when
when you're storage becomes out-of-date
now you put your movies on it like
that's the worst case scenario for Chea
becoming massive or your consciousness
exactly maybe upload happen sooner yeah
yeah right now we recently had David
Eagleman
showing he was teaching us that right
now as they map every single one of the
trillions of connections that's out in
the brain that it actually takes
zettabyte
just and that's like what well and it's
also a little scary because there was a
I forget the name of the law but a
Moore's Law equivalent for how much your
drive space you know halved in price
every 18 to 24 months that's slowing
down right yeah in both hard drive an
SSD now it might be somewhat the
transition because you know the drive
manufacturers have a hard time of I
can't have my revenue loss and selling
spinning but I really want to go to
solid state yeah still it's kind of a
scary point that you know we're we're
heading toward potentially some physical
limits of how much to or should get
cheaper and then we're also storing in
DNA this was very interesting and so
much smaller so much less more energy
but yeah look look I said you know if we
got to the point where there were on
doors building DNA hard drives of Chia
yeah we want we've like you know not
nothing bad is happening there because
those are gonna be useful for that
zettabyte of you yeah exactly right yep
okay so and then we got yeah I see those
are broken this is the other major
innovation you know I ran a public
company music did it the hard way by
buying a shell and moving it to Nasdaq
and so have had a kind of more insider
view of how the SEC and the Nasdaq
really work and I was watching these
American Aiko's go on and it's just like
I'm sorry that's illegal right you're
selling equity and to unregistered
investors like no you can't do that
right but there's no real reason to fear
the SEC a lot of people I think think of
the SEC as the Enforcement Division
because that's what gets the news but
the SE C's job is capital formation it's
its whole actual reason for being is to
make it easier and to make sure that you
know investors are both protected but
that they're real investment
opportunities in those things scale and
after the 2008 crisis there were some
new changes to SEC laws and I think the
crisis kind of overshadowed the changes
and it took them kind of a couple years
to realize they were there and what it's
called regulation A+ what regulation A+
is part of the crowdfunding programs
they've come up
it'll allow companies to raise up to
fifty million dollars a year if they're
audited and up to twenty-five million
dollars a year if they're not audited
but just reviewed right and we looked at
this and went we should do an actual
equity offering right you know when
you're stuck when you're working with a
brand-new enterprise that is absolutely
being backed by you know Bram Cohen
myself others Ryan's work you know
you're making an investment right you're
hoping for an outcome that returns you
money well let's make it clear that it's
an investment and then let's distribute
those coins to shareholders because then
you have all the pieces you need you
know clearly one pieces equity clearly
one piece is a commodity it would
actually have a cap table correct and
you don't live and invest and Wimbley a
public company and so not only it sounds
like a really good way to transition
it's a much better way right because you
know you're saying look we're making you
know SEC reviewed comments about factual
statements you know
yes groups of space will do this yes
proofs of time we'll do that this is our
delivery timeline this is how much cash
we have you're putting skin in the game
that's right yeah yeah and you're saying
look there's no reason not to look over
our shoulder and let's do it right yeah
let's do right yeah I like that I think
that that increases the transparency of
everything that's going on it makes it
easier for other people to understand
what's going on for other people to get
involved in what's going on that's right
and it offers all the classic investor
protections right you know we're gonna
go to quarterly reporting you don't
necessarily have to for other ICS but
again I think we want to in some ways be
hyper compliant I mean one of the things
that's holding Bitcoin back is its
original I think misbranding as you know
drugs and money laundering right and by
being compliant by being green by being
well known we want people to start
thinking about the real use cases right
you know it is things like if you're
Venezuelan cryptocurrency is the only
way you've saved your wealth right you
know it's it's impossible to banking
transactions in East Africa right
solving those problems first is
important but look you know been raising
some money right and I have these
moments where I'm talking international
investors and we're literally watching
the bank system steal like 20 bucks here
teen bucks there are say it's gonna take
15 days to send $50,000 we the running
joke is I'm like we're investing in
these things to stop this yes yes seen
days invested it's crazy yeah no that
should be you know a couple minutes
you know like well-known say Canadian
bank well-known US bank 15 days $75
apiece yeah yeah that's nonsense right
and there yeah let's get rid of
middlemen that are doing that doing
badly yeah so you know be a company
right you know company in seven exactly
put put our skin in the game of saying
you know these are the risks maybe you
don't want to invest right but these are
the rewards we believe them they're
forward-looking statements you can't
guarantee him but you know this is how
you interact with companies and the sec
recently has been saying the same sorts
of things where they're saying you know
look some of these coins may very well
transition from being securities to
being utility tokens like they look at
bitcoin and go that is a coin it's a
piece of property it's not a security
right well we're saying let's
disambiguate it clearly right if you're
a shareholder you're a shareholder right
we're making promises to you about
outcomes right but for court home you
don't have the same problem now though
obviously be a lot of overlap between
shareholders and coin holders initially
but you know in some ways gia networks
really long-term view is how do we get
ourselves out of even being necessary
for Chia you know you don't want to have
a single point of failure even perceived
single point of failure right but when
you build these things initially some
centralization helps to really get going
and make those initial decisions and
then move things forward in the
community way yep and then just has this
last slide on timeline you guys are you
know finishing up regular IPO yeah we're
actually gonna follow the suc here
shortly and your question is always what
time it takes the sec I will say that
usually 60 days is a pretty accurate
view of you know kind of the questions
that suc will have about the sorts of
filings on the one hand we're a little
novel on the other hand you know we've
been involved with making sure they
understand what we want to do and I have
this I've your domain here open
and I want to just you know also
showcase this cuz it's really
interesting Chia dotnet the links in the
bio green money for digital world
building a blockchain based on proofs of
space and time to make a cryptocurrency
is less wasteful more decentralized more
secure
kind of talked about things now - you
know maybe I want to know if you is the
is your proof of space and time is that
also listed under the you know talks and
papers that you've done there are talks
Braham has kind of you know good
overviews of and good technical deeps we
also have quite a few you know we don't
have been a lot of talk that's right
yeah we don't have a white paper we have
peer-reviewed publish academic papers
quite intentionally you know we were
taking some time to get this right to
make sure it's secure to build a you
know a better bitcoin and it's not just
proof of space design that's the big
thing but like there's a lot of things
where you know it's a ten year old
product and it shows some croft so we
just released a BL s signature library
that stands for what again gosh one of
our advisors names i can't remember i
apologize but the idea is that the way
digital signatures worked in Bitcoin
today multi-sig and wallets can be kind
of hard to do yeah BLS you can sign
something and I can sign something not
at the same time not in the same place
yeah you can add those two together and
those two signatures add yeah and that
shows that it's still signed so it's
things like that to shrink the size of
the blockchain for example I'm going to
make multi-sig wallets much much easier
to do you know so there's some really
neat new crypto that's kind of happened
in the last five years that we're gonna
adopt into that blockchain hmm okay so I
like that I think there's a good amount
of people that are tackling the
multi-sig situation also the the
decreasing the amount of space that
everything actually ends up taking this
is this is uh I'm happy to hear to learn
about sin to hear about this and you
know we initially met at Silicon Valley
blockchain Society and it was great to
hear you guys present there as well and
so Bram Cohen is leading this that's
right that's very interesting the very
Rd focused company as you can imagine
super
and you know one of the things I'd say
is that it's our goal to be one of the
most Rd friendly blockchains period
there's a lot of things that a lot of
Bitcoin core developers and others would
really like to add or do to Bitcoin and
you know these this minor investment in
a6 and Power has led them to be very
conservative have been worried about you
know feature changes and all of this and
you know by not having any kind of
central focused entity saying this is
how you should do it we think we can you
know really advance those things we all
know we'd like to do so you know time
locks and escrow and inheritance I mean
there's all these features that would be
really nice yes and we think we can do
them better more efficiently and quicker
on Gia and then what is the main sort of
programming language of the gia Network
it's C underneath and then it's Python
generally around right so you know
because the performance you know good
old-fashioned C C++ keep the place to be
but you know at the more application
level Python okay and that's where you
can build out things like escrow or
inheritance well and some of this is
actually you know having some of the
core guys have more tools and easier to
use stuff like we're gonna change how
script works because it can be pretty
ugly right now in Bitcoin and we're
gonna take some things away that will
still allow you to do a lot of the
features you want but make them much
more secure it's those kinds of things
that we're trying to do to bring the
kind of Bitcoin quite code base into the
future awesome okay so that's pretty
that's pretty solid on on Qi I got you
know I got so much more to learn as I'm
so ignorant about box chains and
cryptocurrencies I want to keep learning
as much as possible and keep
disseminating and keep inspiring people
to to use them and you know we have we
we now accept cryptocurrency the link
links in the bio although it's a coin
base account that's right hey guys start
somewhere
and I started somewhere exactly okay so
let's also talk about AE token some of
the work there
see I have I have pulled up here a token
safeguards it increases all your
affiliate revenue and deals in one place
okay yeah so you know first of all I
think every IC o---- comes with
skepticism these days
and I have a lot of the same skepticism
and it's one of the reasons I like this
project is it's solving a couple very
real problems so you may have heard a
basic attention token brave and the tend
to kind of go after the advertising
industry to make it so that you know the
viewers cut in and the ad fraud falls
and all those sorts things well there's
also a you know primary traffic driving
way called affiliate marketing and you
know around the globe different
industries use it differently like here
in the US
Amazon still has a very significant
affiliate program but you know there are
a lot of jurisdictions where what the
affiliates drive traffic to things like
online casinos completely legal glutton
legitimate Americans hate it and you
know it's a very big business now it's
weird because it's so patchwork you
haven't had kind of these monoliths you
know there's no facebook of this market
right but you've got a lot of these kind
of medium to small businesses like ten
guys driving traffic to you know any
commerce site in Germany and they're
making enough money to easily you know
afford to run the business but it
doesn't only scale beyond that but they
run into huge problems problem number
one is that most these guys get paid out
in Skrill which is kind of global
Facebook global PayPal and so all of the
nasty things you ever heard about PayPal
you know apply enforce so you know
there's extremely expensive currency
exchange rates you can only take out so
much per day one of my friends in this
world bottomer Sade's he had to convince
the mercedes dealer that he could only
pay him about 121 for the next 21 days
to buy it in cash right so you know
their accounts get frozen
you know things go well and that means
you can't access your money really
horribly painful and obviously one of
those things that a cryptocurrency has a
lot of value for plus there's also a
real kind of pyramid of division so you
know you'll have a site and you'll have
a super affiliate and you'll have a
bunch of sub affiliates and so you have
people who are owed like a nickel and in
the past it's not worth paying somebody
a nickel because there's absolutely no
way from a fees perspective that that
makes sense
so like people would have their balances
sit for months until they added up to
something that was worth transferring
well the divisibility of cryptocurrency
obviously is very relevant to that
problem you know all of a sudden now
it's like here here's a tenth of a cent
you're paid up right and any other issue
is that these are very international
businesses so
we'll have a caiman corporation striking
a deal with a Malta corporation and you
know if one of the sides welches on the
deal well the reality is there's no way
to sue each other because you know Oh
Suman came and get an expert of them all
you know it's a very very large contract
that even makes it worth suing in the
first place so we're enabling pre-loaded
arbitration with mediators so that you
know normally transaction goes through
mediator gets an extremely tiny fee just
for having you know been there and been
available but you know if you actually
have a problem now there's recourse and
you know you've got coins out there
locked waiting for this resolution of
your dispute so all of a sudden both
sides are actually you know forced to
play fair and we think that's actually
increased the size of the affiliate
market and I like how you're describing
sort of this well this is definitely
applicable to content creators totally
rather than having someone else solve
advertisements to your space and etc you
can bring in people that have your same
values you can then advertise on their
behalf you can then get maybe a more
fair play between the two well you know
in the past I think folks like you know
yourself even right now you kind of got
to use a third party service and that
service takes its hunk and it's not
necessarily is easily managed you know
making this become something that
smaller you know individual youtubers or
others can use directly and build their
own programs and now it's just a
software problem and all of the
back-office problems of paying people
out all that is now pushed away because
you use this kind of currency and
instead of just using Bitcoin straight
up you know you can have lower fees
you're gonna have hopefully less
volatility because you actually have a
functioning market where like affiliate
websites are buying it to then pay it to
their affiliates who are then spending
it for you know paying the rent and so
how long has a token been around about
70 months we're currently about to do a
non-us offering out of Malta
so Malta has become one of the very
leading European especial
domiciles for either utility tokens or
security tokens and why Malta again I
think it's that let regulatory lead
where you lead and why are they had in
terms of they've been very open to
understanding this you know it's one of
the situations where they've classically
been a business friendly Haven and they
saw the kind of Rhett rise of icos and
said okay let's start putting together
some of the best practices let's adopt
what I'd call a light framework not
dissimilar to what the SEC is doing here
in the US and that way you have a lot
more regulatory certainty able to say to
people yep there is a you know you EC
country that this business is domiciled
in these are your you know investor
protections there there's actually a
regulatory environment instead of just
being a Wild West the perfection is the
enemy of execution of getting [ __ ] done
and so if you're constantly waiting to
build out the best possible framework of
regulation you'll never actually build
one out and take it too long so it's
almost like they started with this
toddler face of a framework and then
that's enabling people to come in and
then they're gonna upgrade it over time
well it's somewhat likely you know
Delaware courts right like you know
people don't kind of know this but like
the Delaware courts have optimized
themselves for businesses so you can get
rulings from the Delaware courts in like
a week yeah these are the things that
don't work but it's all about business
and so Malta both legislatively and
judicially it's kind of done this
they've said look we want to be experts
we're gonna start here or you know as
individual projects have issues bring
them to us and we'll modify the
legislation moving for it right it's
that kind of responsiveness and a true
engagement that becomes very interesting
because it's like there are certainly
good things that came out of old
securities regulations right you know
pump and dumps were always pumping dumps
the world does not change completely but
there's a whole bunch of stuff that just
is not relevant anymore because you know
things like you know does your security
exist well you can go look on the
blockchain and see that it does right so
there's a whole host of differences that
are relatively poor fits and so having
these regions that aren't willing to
look at that and go okay you know we're
gonna and that we're to bring the
general investor protections
but then we're gonna look those and make
sure they actually fit for what's going
on and be small enough to be able to
actually yeah light enough that a small
team who's trying to raise a small
amount of money can go do them that's
awesome thank you for that heads up so
okay so in I mean I'm looking this up
here that you know we're looking it up
here that in the Malta is in the central
Mediterranean between Sicily in the
North African coast but do we know what
the population is I'm gonna look it's
pretty small it's not you know it's not
dissimilar like a came in or various
it's also somewhat of a population just
wonder 500,000 yeah so they're really
able to just pivot in you know yep but
you know euro banking you've got access
to the year the European banking system
yeah that's also very cool right yeah
because they're part of the EU they are
okay interesting yeah they're right
there salt just south of Sicily that's
so interesting
less than 500,000 people in there so
what we're we're we're the other kind of
hubs aren't we had some in the Caribbean
as well right well so actually on the
crypto side I'd say more like
Switzerland Singapore have both been
looking at this yeah you know there's a
lot of business in Hong Kong whether
that's shall we say well understood or
not that's a major hub both Japan and
Korea have tremendous cryptocurrency
markets as well but but for the more
regulatory side of it its tended to be
Switzerland Singapore
you know Malta as we said cool that's
that's really important to to know is
that like which places are able to lead
well look you know I I laughingly guess
which will it's got an expensive and I
also worry a little bit that like what
we're trying to do is put banks out of
business and what Switzerland does is
Bank yeah yeah ding so there's there was
actually six point eight billion dollars
in revenue generated by the affiliate
industry in 2007 that's right and that's
just like us in the UK right so there's
yeah there's bigger numbers out there
especially China and
and again it's been difficult to manage
these systems so you know making these
systems making the painful parts of
those systems go away makes it a far
less painful project and run yeah
a token is very exciting as well
anywhere where there's like a two-sided
market and it's not 80/20 you know
you've usually got these power laws
going on these businesses when there's a
broad open market and you know this is
where like the uber model goes right you
got a bunch of drivers you've got a
bunch of riders there's no kind of
dominant entity that happens in the
middle market here in the token world
almost all the way to the tail those are
the kinds of economies where you know
tokenization really makes some sense and
where you may not just want to use
Bitcoin or Chia directly because you
need some extra features that aren't
ready yet or aren't there yet on some of
the other chains awesome I think that
okay there's a couple things that I
think we should talk about
let's I'll flip I'll flip over this this
15 times so that was that's there at 35
now right 3830 perfect thank you
thanks Eddy so let's ask you a couple
thoughts I guess the first thought that
I want to ask you is this is kind of a
funny thought but what who do you think
Satoshi is so yeah so I'm pretty
confident how Phineas part of Satoshi
how well fini fini yeah so how funny is
rel is already well-established as being
the guy who Satoshi first started
talking to yeah and you know obviously
Nick's as Bo comes up as being part of
it it certainly wasn't just how right so
I do think there was more than just how
but you know how and some other folks
that are kind of old cypherpunks this is
their mo in fact just after house death
Phil Zimmerman a PGP admitted that it
was how who'd exported PGP and was a was
supposedly would would have been the
target investigation but Phil stepped in
and took the public face of it
intentionally and so this is exactly
how's em oh plus as Bram's been digging
into the code you know there are a lot
of signatures of how Hal coded and they
are very much in the original release
it's a Toshi interesting i had also
heard things like we've got a machine
look look the whole the whole AI comes
back from the future is always
interesting but the funny thing about
that is you know excluding that it's all
in AI yeah stepping that aside at that
moment in time there were like four or
five different researchers that had all
the pieces so you know the state of the
art was there on the table just nobody
had pulled it together and that's often
one of the hardest problems but yes
partially why doesn't feel like it like
was air dropped in by aliens if you
don't say it was someone who you know
like how is often credited for being one
of the predecessors with Hashcash right
and it was thinking hit that and some
other things he was reading and you know
pulled together and really figuring out
that like grinding was actually a
security feature I mean these are weird
thoughts right but you know like a lot
of internet things the hack version is
actually the best version this is kind
of we've we've talked about this before
as being the in a couple decades ago the
internet all these new applications have
been built on the Internet
now this is kind of this new blockchain
infrastructure all these new
applications are being built on the
blockchain infrastructure we both know
that a lot of them are going to die um
and that Cambrian explosion the Cambrian
explosion
exactly I'm boom so what now what what
do you think are the main principles or
characteristics that have to be at the
core of these organizations in order for
them to live so I think there's a couple
things I mean I think you've got to be
in these multi-sided markets right
because one of the things that like you
know the real use of the blockchain is
when there's not a lot of trust it's a
way to build trust into trust this
manner right so any place where there is
those kinds of agency problems and he
doesn't trust the other side but you
need to coordinate yeah very very strong
application the more moving of money is
core to what you're trying to do and the
fungibility of that and the ease of that
right that's again where a blockchain or
a side chain starts to really matter
right I think there's a little stretch
right now to try to build some
applications directly against the
blockchain I actually think the
applications would be more interesting
up on like Lightning Network in these
kind of next layer up technology is
where you know down below the Chea
blockchain of the Bitcoin watch-chain
are hyper secure a lot more conservative
about changes you know if you're buying
a house you're doing it on the
blockchain if you're buying coffee
you're doing it on lightning yeah right
and you know it's the way the world
currently works there's an observe
infrastructure like you know member the
gold and down in 9/11 that they had to
remove I mean that's the underlying
baking infrastructure right in fact like
the French in the 60s when the dollar
was unpaid from gold tried to grab their
gold back by bringing a destroyer to New
York Harbor like they wanted it loaded
right we don't move the gold much right
yeah but you know layer up you've got
Swift which is actually like a private
Internet and it's not actually what
people kind of think it is but Swift is
the way the bank's talk and then you've
got you know libel war there's the bank
window about how they want each other
and you've got the Fed and so you got
all these things that then kind of
bubble up to debit cards at a CH and
then PayPal well we're gonna have to do
exact same sorts of layering I think the
layers and be lab thinner you know maybe
three layers you know the thing you use
to that your computer uses to talk to
another computer and make sure that
you're real and you know you exchange
two cents and you don't know about in
the background and you know you keep
your account loaded with with 20 bucks
and when you look in it there's 18
dollars sometimes there's 21 dollars
other times right so on lightning and
just a quick question on here how would
we then insure because with a card right
now I'm I'm sure a hundred percent of
transactions are going through so
lightning uses both kind of time and the
main blockchain so the idea is is that
you'll build a channel so you know I
will connect and I will put some money
in and I'll pay you a buck well that
channel stays open as you talk to other
people you now know how to reach me and
you can see that I've gotten more money
and so if I want to pay him I can pass
it through you now if one of us cheats
we can kind of take it from a timestamp
where that cheat happened stop and roll
it all the way back yeah yeah and that
way it's enforced by the security the
annoying watching so it's constantly
being analyzed to make sure that there's
not that's right and if it is then you
go back to where it was your iPhone or
Android is we're going to watch your
channels too
make sure transactions are legit legit
all the time and it'll stop it if it's
not it'll roll it back and all the suds
that coins will go where they're
supposed to go yeah I like that that
makes a lot of sense for lightning yeah
it's long it's somewhat like it's like
check it right I mean behind the scenes
in the checking business you know you
can call your bank and they can go
figure out what bank put it through and
you know you can unroll the transact
which takes it easy right yeah I can do
it right and I have it be automated as
such a pleasure well you know one of the
funny things about all of this is to get
people to use e-commerce online we all
train them use their credit cards and so
now they've got this assumption that
every transaction they make they can
make a phone call and reverse it right
it is a tremendous problem like the
reason that like Venetia existed was
because everybody had to move to
subscription because of the underlying
economics of the credit card in the
structure it's not something the outside
world kind of sees much but chargebacks
and all the fees that work underneath
mean that you can't really sell
something for 50 cents well I'm looking
forward to you know we've seen the kind
of rise and maybe the peak of
subscription I'm looking for the world
where lightning and other things starts
getting to the yeah you can give
somebody 10 cents and it doesn't it's
only fully thought yeah I'm so excited
for that as well there's this whole
project that one of my friends Jackson
was really working really closely on and
then I was definitely engaged with them
on the idea a lot and just this is
general notion of being paid person per
second of time such an interesting idea
yeah I mean you know there's always the
you gotta think about it right and see
it be careful about making sure things
are priced in ways that humans know you
know it's too expensive to even think
right yeah but and there's a whole
transactional economy side of things
like you know I don't want you to have
to come into the show and then for you
to have to pay us per second or
something stupid like that but but at
the same time it makes sense though for
maybe in the case of that you want to
talk to somebody that's really prominent
that can help your company out a lot and
you don't know them you don't have a
warm connection to them and they can
maybe open up a you know a couple of
dollars per second line so that you can
call them and talk to them in that sense
give feedback well you know and look
there there's a kind of other hidden
thing here immutability you know we had
crypto kitties right but there are other
people looking at this and going I'd
love to have a hundred I don't know a
hundred bill of cats in this world right
and there will only ever be a hundred
well you know right now it's kind of
hard to charge something a buck for that
right but I can completely see a world
where you charge a dollar for that that
dollar price works economically and the
chain itself also enforces the only 100
of them will ever exist Yeah right and
you can transfer them right yeah you
know there's a whole kind of all of the
virtual economy things that Warcraft and
other major games sort of play with are
now gonna be not just virtual but may be
you know far beyond the walls of gaming
yeah that's that's so exciting as well
okay so a couple quick questions on the
way out one of them that we these are a
couple that we asked on the show a lot
gene do you think we're alone in the
cosmos you know I'm worried that the
Occam's razor answer is that we are
right now you know the interesting
question is are we creating do Dyson
spheres get created faster than the e/m
radiation moves out right so that's
that's one interesting way that the math
doesn't work on you know the conjecture
right
I certainly hope we're not I'll say it
that way but you know right now the
evidence does not look pretty and do you
think that were in a simulation I don't
think we're in a simulation it's hard to
explain why I mean you're down to
philosophy right and it's actually to me
one of the most interesting questions
about AI and uh blood right I mean you
know is there something intrinsic to
biology beyond simply chemistry and
mathematics that we're not aware of
right you know I am NOT a very religious
person but the thing is is you know how
you get that neural net started is an
interesting question
you know some of the reasons why upload
seems a little safer in the sense of
maybe that is how you take a running
version right and keep it running but
how do you start it from scratch that's
a really interesting question yeah I
really enjoy the you know the mind is
being molded in the womb and the mind
comes out and it starts perceiving an
environment starts forming all the
circuitry in the mind yeah how can that
all be you know
how can that be both computationally
mapped over time but then also be
potentially simulated in a sense so this
is you know I kind of agree with
Kurzweil in the sense that like I think
we're going to get to human digital
interface depth faster and then once you
do that you start you know melding the
best of both yeah and then I think we
might be able to answer that question
you know the first people who fully
upload and fork are gonna be very
interesting right yeah so you just said
the word fork and I and I do want to
sorry well I want I want it I want to
see your perspective on this it isn't
something that we talked about on the
show quite a bit and then I got one last
question for you but just the the
general Pinker argument about everybody
slowly coming up over time is very true
economically but at the same time we've
never seen an exponential technology age
like we do today
do you suspect like a forking in terms
of just the sheer amount of genetic
engineering and brain uploading and all
this different stuff cryptocurrencies
yeah look I think you're always gonna
have the first people who get adopted
right you know right now on any
technology via cryptocurrency the early
developers you know are wealthy beyond
most people's dreams right you know this
always happens look Tesla you know a
bunch of us own Model S's and a whole
bunch more people going to model threes
finally you know and that that shifts
down now it's interesting with that
exponentiation you know that first
uploader has a hell of an advantage but
at the same time I think it's gonna be
like the computer revolution of the
first uploads probably gonna feel like a
victory right you know and that's not
exactly the most fun thing out there in
fact look as part of the problem current
infrastructure of the blockchain world I
think we're in the trs-80 era of blah
chance you don't you don't suspect I
agree with you but you you don't you
don't you suspect that even though that
the first initial adopters that the that
the bottom will still be coming up super
quickly over time that there won't be
any sort of a speciation like where we
should be pretty good
you know I we're still an altruistic
species right you know there's still
that 72 member tribe and so you at least
want the 70-member tribe and in each
seventy-two once they're 72 right I mean
I think that that is where we go and you
start getting to the question of what's
the core cause
it's probably energy again this is why I
said folks that they're going let's make
sure we're not wasting up on other
things that zettabyte that's right yeah
okay Jean last question what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world hmm the most beautiful thing in
the world I don't probably selfish
answer but being 50 or 60 miles offshore
I love when you know experiencing how
huge our actual world art is you know
people talk about all these things
further I think a lot of folks haven't
been sure Duff from land or far enough
from civilization in the desert really
get a sense of how big this world
already is I mean it makes it makes the
thought of going to Mars you know really
exciting yeah oh I love I love the day
idea of exploring or an exploring other
frontiers that's a good one so you go
you love 50 60 miles off offshore yeah
interesting and then it's over the
horizon right yeah it's like you now are
truly responsible for everything of your
own safety you know if you go float
further you're now out of helicopter
range you know it's it's a different
world out there yeah yeah yeah and
that's where you just death is so close
to okay yeah well you know it's it's you
are at the net mother nature's mercy and
and it's the ultimate test of your
technology and your skill right you know
did you correctly make redundant tech is
it well tested do you know what you're
doing what you know what do you do it
same thing in the desert exhaust saying
as well and I love those do damn okay
awesome this has been such a good
episode thank you so much for coming on
accusing us yeah better grab two
currencies has been such a pleasure
thank you yeah I think there's so much
that we can still learn I think there is
you know thanks everybody for tuning in
you know think about what we talked
about you know better cryptocurrencies
how can we figure out these new sort of
systems of proof of time proof of space
also just what is the next advancements
in blockchain technology encrypt or
currency technology how can we get more
people involved in the conversations of
starting them also think about how all
these applications work in our lives and
let's remember don't just consume this
content go and create with it make blogs
make videos make companies go and start
cool things with
subscribe comment below with your
thoughts we'd love for you to join the
community join us on patreon hope to
support this project help us increase
our impact more people would greatly
appreciate that thanks Eddie
thank you so much for producing and
directing our show Eddie comm check them
out as well
much love everyone thank you peace
okay we are awesome